hello everyone we said we were gonna
show one more game from round nine of
the 2019 sinful Cup and then discuss the
standings a bit it's a Wesley Silver
City on a pony show and it really is a
really a terrific grind so if you don't
have the stomach for a long grind you
maybe want to skip this one but if you
do let's just enjoy it so without
further ado Wesley with the white pieces
opens with Knight to f3 the reti is on
the board and we have c5 by nepo
inviting Wesley to either play E 4 and
transposing into a Sicilian or maybe C 4
and transport transpose into the English
opening which Wesley does so nice the c6
we continue with the English Knights the
c3 and now g6 nipple prepares the Veneto
his dark square Bishop with III and now
Knight to f6 with d4 grabbing or more
space in the center C capture some
before e capture some d4 and now d5
weave seek after some d5 Knight captures
and e5 ending out Queen to b3 pressuring
the night here so here you can either
defend it you could capture on c3 but
this way white gets the Bishop to c4 in
before recapturing as the f7 point is
now threatened so once black defends it
now you capture on c3 or also playable
but after Queen b3
nepo prefers east 6 right away so Bishop
to b5 by Wesley Bishop to g7 preparing
the castle and both players castle now
now that the knight on c6 is no longer
pinned and the ways to take this
opportunity to create an isolated pawn
on c6 with Bishop captures B captures
and now Knight to a4 not only does black
have a and isolated opponent C since but
also white now has an excellent outpost
on c5 for his Knight and you will not be
able to kick the night away from there
as you don't have a B pond or a deep on
we have Queen to d6 just developing the
Queen preparing to develop the light
square Bishop and rook to e1 will rook
to b8 pushing away the Queen Queen back
to d1 and now Knight back to East 7 here
black has a an isolated C pawn but white
also has an isolated deep on and now
black hole reading nicely attacks the
point with the bishop and the Queen now
the idea is Knight East 75 and from f5
the knight will also be attacking the d4
pawn so black has a weakness but white
also has a weakness
so 97 going after the f5 squared to
attack the d4 phone with b3y prepares
Bishop to b2 to add another defender to
the b4 pawn and now Knight to f5 honing
in on the weakness with Bishop to b2 and
now rook to d8 adding another attacker
to the d4 pawn and here white has no
more ways of adding more the more
defenders to the pawn you could play
something like rook e8 but that's that's
just weird
so there is one game in the database
it's actually from the women's
candidates tournament Alexandre chorin
versus Maria Musa choke where rook the
c1 was played that game ended in a draw
also the idea is just going after after
all the trades on before you will be
able to recapture deployment c6 but here
we have Queen to c2 it's not a new
movies being played before but the idea
is similar so we have a lot of trades in
the center now with Knight captures on
d4 Bishop captures on B for worship
characters we have captures captures and
now not captures right away because if
you capture on c6 you get Bishop to d7
and well you're gonna lose the knight on
e4 you're not gonna lose a piece but you
will get your own structure messed up
for example Queen f3 now you capture and
after recapture screen captures on a4
and you will end this variation being a
being down a pawn so instead after Queen
captures on before we have rook a to d1
now you have to be careful otherwise
you're gonna lose the rook on d8 Queen
to f6 and now also there is one game in
the database for Quintus c3 was played
Queen c3 was played between more oddly
and Safari in 2019 and that game ended
with black winning after rook character
sandy won rook after sandy v black
didn't win because white played Queen c3
I was just you know a different line was
played about black one in the end here
we have rook captures on d8 instead
so rook captures and e8 with Czech Queen
captures on b8 recapturing and now just
rook to d1 Wesley prefers this area I
believe rook captures unbe 8 sorry
forgot to mention this rook captures and
d8 was still not a new move in the game
I believe yeah I think route no I
actually don't remember where where the
new move in the game was so sorry about
that I know that when we moved into that
position yeah rook captures NBA I think
rock after sandy it is the new move in a
new position but I will have to check
and if if it is I'm not gonna say
anything if it's not I will mention
something in the comments so rock
characters on the 8th and we have a
completely new game Queen captures on
the 8th and the now rook to d1 just
grabbing hold of the D file Quinta I ate
and now h3 creating some space for a
white King and now II five Network
continues pushing the pawn or maybe even
f5 can be played we have Queen to c5 now
going after a seven and now comes a six
just defending Queen to a5 Wesley now
prepares rook to the 8th to win the
Queen and so King to g7 and just getting
the King out of the way
rook to d8 and the now comes Queen to e7
and here a very interesting move by
Wesley a very creative move Knight to b6
so obviously you're giving up a knight
but in return you're picking up a pawn
with check
so you're grabbing your pawn back and
picking up the rook on b8 since the
bishop is still undeveloped on c8 and
the Nemesis all right let's do this with
Queen captures on d8 the Queen captures
on e5 with Czech Queen to f6 blocking
and now Queen captures unbe 8 so where's
the one has pawn back and Bishop to e6
so now we have this position where the
material on the board is equal although
as you can see where's the nipple has
three porn islands it Wesley has only
two point island so it is white should
be a little bit better as the two points
might become easy targets maybe not if
the Queen's are on the board but if the
Queen's get off the board
and definitely it will be the case Queen
back to g3 by Wesley and now h5 the
problem is if you go for this pawn grab
with Queen a1 check King h2 and Queen
captures and a2 then Queen e5 check
ensures the draw because if you look at
the pawns and the bishop they're all on
light squares so you're really not all
that great on the dark square so you can
just continue checking if you go here
then you're getting you're just lost g4
is coming and so on so I have to go back
25 check you can go Kia faith Queen b6
check you're gonna go back King G H now
Queen B 8 b8 check King g7 you're gonna
go back and so on you're gonna continue
checking the black King along the dark
squares so for the moment it's
impossible to go for this pawn grab but
the nipple prepares it with h5 now the
King also has the h7 square to hide from
all the checks on the dark squares with
Knights to a4 by Wesley and now you he
wants to activate a knight but now never
goes for the pawn with nights the Quinta
1 check King 2 h2 and now Queen captures
on a 2 and now Knight the c5 now if
Queen e5 check we said that now you can
hide on h7 and there are no more checks
so Knights the c5 going after Knight
captures Bishop which would really mess
up black's pawn structure so you you get
Queen to e to the Queen now guards the
bishop with Quintus III check King to g8
and the now Queen to d4 a nice
centralizing move with the Queen will
rush up to d5 now putting the bishop to
a very dangerous diagonal and now Knight
to d7 going for Knight f6 check and from
there things can get very dangerous so
Queen to East 6 now getting the Queen
Queen back into the defense nice the f6
check and now King to f8 and B 4 now
this one point will be used to control
both of both of nepos spawns the apron
and the C pawn since they are still on
light sports and Wesley's B for ponies
on a dark square you cannot attack it
with the bishop since the bishop is
light square Bishop and the Queen will
be on
about to do anything about it since
Wesley's Queen is also keeping an eye on
the poem so we have Queen 2d6
with check King back to G 1 and now
kinked East 7 now never starts bringing
the King into the game which is not
something you see very often when the
Queen's are still on the board
we have night the g8 check and now even
King the e6 we have Queen to f6 check
this is really crazy King to d7 and the
now comes Quinta d4 just bringing the
Queen back to keep an eye on the be for
pawn with Queen 38 not allowing this
infiltration with Quinta a7 also keeping
an eye on the b4 pawn and now Knight
back to f6 with check King e6 and now
Knight to e4 capturing that d5 also
doesn't do anything for black so Wesley
goes Knight to e4 and napal decides that
it's time to trade with Bishop captures
Queen captures with check King d7 so
here you can see that it's Queen and
pawn and game where nepo is up upon but
can he actually do anything about it
well one thing he can try is he can try
you can try to grind it out if it's
possible with Quincy for going after the
f7 pawn queen teh defending the pawn now
the idea is that if you kept running a
six Queen e1 check you'll have to either
move the king or play Queen a front you
lose the beaver pond and now Black gets
a pass C pawn which is pretty much
enough for for a win so after Queen e8
Queen back to d4 check with King to c8
and now Queen to b6 going after the pawn
and now black uses a series of checks to
Raymond Raymond over the Queen over to
b5 we have Queen e1 check King h2 and
Queen to e5 check g3 and now Queen to b5
guarding both of the pawns we have Queen
to a7 Queen to b7 pushing the Queen back
Quinta c7 and now circa Quinta c5 and
now Quinta c7 with h4 by white not
allowing h4 by black as that was the
threat and now King back the b7 now the
king is keeping an eye on both of the
pawns and on the Queen side with Queen
to f8 just you know
waiting to see what black will play also
keeping an eye on the f7 pawn and now
Queen d7 we have King back to G 1 and
now Queen to d5 with King back to h2 and
now King to c7 again never sees that
there is no way of bringing through here
with only the Queen so you have to try
and bring the King into the game Kim
Jiwan we have King d7 King back to h2
and now Queen to c4 we have King back to
g1 and now Queen back to e6 with Queen
to c5 and now Queen to d2 Queen to d4
check with King to e6 now again bringing
the Queen King deeper into the position
Queen to c5 and now Queen b5 clearing
the fifth-ranked for the black king we
have Queen III check and now King to f6
now you can try entering the position
well maybe King g5 King g4 maybe even
King h3 if it's possible who knows
Queen c3 check and sorry not f3 Queen c3
check and now came back to e7 we have
Queen to d4 not allowing the black King
to enter the position King back to e6 we
have Quinta III check King to d7 and now
Queen to a7 check with King Teti 8 and
now Queen back to d4 Queen to d5
offering the Queen trade of course
Wesley declines this Queen to b6 and now
Queen to c4 again keeping an eye on all
the three weaknesses here we have Queen
to b8 check King to e7 and now Queen to
e5 check King b7 so still not able to do
anything about it
Queen to b8 just keeping an eye on the
b4 pawn and came to e6 with Queen t8
check came to f5 and now Queen to e7
again keeping an eye on the b4 pawn
queen d5 and then out comes Queen to e2
we have Queen to b5 again offering a
queen trade and Queen back to e7 with
Queen to c4 and now Queen to be 8 Wesley
can only wait and see what nipple will
do and if nipple makes a some sort of a
bad rash decision then
of course try to punish it with Queen to
e6 again offering a trade and now Queen
to d8 with King to e4 now the king is
already quite active on e4 with Queen to
d2 preparing to pull the King back Queen
the c-4 keeping an eye on the squares
that were wise can deliver check but
also Queen to III is possible to deliver
check King a5 and now Queen back to e7
now the King can be pulled back with
Queen to g5 for example but King to g4
and now it's very interesting you can
deliver Queen to g5 choke but if you
deliver Queen to g5 check what can black
play black can play King to h3 and now
it's very problematic you can no longer
check the black King as all of these
squares are nicely covered by the pawns
and once you make a move and try to do
it
you're either losing this pawn or if you
give up the light squares you can either
get even get to checkmate it so if you
allow King h3 you're lost so Queen to d7
check not giving up on this diagonal
King to f3 and now Queen to d2
so again hoping for Queen III check but
now
f6 so it's not much but it's something
Queen III check King has to go back in
g4 and now King g2 already with
something maybe with submitting ideas
with f3 if all of if white and cover up
all of the squares soaking back to f5
you know an active King is good a to
active of a king is not good King to h2
and now g5 with H captures F captures
and now Queen to d2 again defending the
b4 pawn with Queen to d5 again offering
the trade and now quinta e 2 we have
Queen to d4 again going after the pond
and here the problem is if you defend it
for example Queen e1
you get h4 after G captures you get pawn
captures and here it will be very
difficult
you're still down upon and black will
have somewhat of an easier task Trading
Queens as you're working is not wide
open so Wesley decides for a different
idea
kingi one but now you lose the be for
pawn with Queen capture son be for knock
on screen of three check King to e5 and
now Queen captures on h5 so now still
only up a pawn but now those are two to
pass points on the Queen side whereas a
White has no passport he may be able to
create one later with at four but for
now he doesn't have any with Queen to be
one with check King g2 and now Queen to
f5 keeping an eye on this pawn and now
he's ready to start pushing the a pawn
we have Queen to d1 and now a5 Queen
back to d8 going after the e5 pawn king
to e4
now the pawn is defended by the Queen we
have Queen to d2 again keeping an eye on
the King D 3 square is available for
checks and now Queen d5 now the check
will be met with a discovered check with
f3 check first came to f5 and now g4
check King back to e6 and now Queen to
c2 we have King to d6 hiding the king
and our king to g3 25 check with King
back to G 2 and now Queen to f4 trying
to support the pawns advancement to a4
with Queen to g6 check King to c7 and
now comes the Queen to h7 check King to
b6 hiding behind his past bonds Queen B
1 check and now Queen before blocking
check with Queen to c1 and now Queen the
c5 Queen back to be to check King gay
sex and the now Queen to a2 and Queen to
b5 now black is ready to continue
pushing the pawns we have Queen to g8
going for some checks on along the
background and now a 4 we have Queen
today a to check King to be 6 and now
Queen to d8 check King to b7 we have
Queen to e7 check and now King back to
a6
Queen the faith you have to prepare
another check but now Queen e2 check
with King to h3 and the now comes Queen
III you will be able to always block
check with Queen to e7 so Queen the a8
check with King the b5 first and now
Queen to b7 with
check win back the b6 and now queen the
g7 and Queen to c5 first we have Queen
to be to check King to a6 and now Queen
sorry Quinta e - again with check King
a7 and now there are no checks from this
position d7 square is covered by the by
the black queen so we have Queen to d2
preparing for more checks but now a3 so
slowly but surely
Neto is pushing the past pawn and
finally a Wesley decides to create a
passport of his own with f/4g capture
screen captures and now Queen the c3
check King to h4 and now Quinta h8 check
King to g5 and the Queen to g8 check we
have Kings to h5 and now Queen d5 check
so again a series of checks the ribbon
over the Queen - a nice central eye
square we have g5 and now a to the Queen
from d5 nicely guards the a2 square we
have Quinta a for check King Tubby 6 and
now Queen to b4 check Queen B five
blocks Queen d4 check and now King back
to a6 and Queen to d8 going for more
checks from behind but now we have Queen
to e to check King to h6 we have Quinta
a6 check g6 and the now Queen to h3
check with King to g5 King to g5 if you
play King to g7 then you get a one queen
with check so this is obviously lost so
after Queen h3 we have King g5 but now
quint the g2 check and it was in this
position I'll move 132 that was Lee so
resigned a game but yeah when he
resigned I think he had some three
seconds on the clock so he didn't feel
like trying to trying to create a try
something here trying to try that sounds
weird but yeah he you know stopped
trying to try something but yeah you can
see it was a it was a really intensive
grind and here he resigns because you
have to play something for example if
King h8 then you get
sorry about that
if if Kinte h6 you can get Quinta h1
with check and now after King to g5 you
will play Queen d5 will to check you
just straight Queens and it's a win for
example now you trade Queens captures
captures and after g7 you get a one
queen white brings the Queen into the
game but now just Queen a to check King
has to move king of six and now you pick
up the Queen and of course it's game
over
so yeah that's the game now let's check
out the standings before we forget but
let's just return to this resigning
position so here are the standings let's
just see what happens here
so in first place after winning in round
nine being Liron and Jana pony she
followed by Vishwanath around and Sarah
Kerrigan with five points then we have
three people with four and a half points
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Quran and chapter
manager of with four points onigiri
Maxine Varsha lagravis Lisa and Aiko
Nakamura and with three and a half
points and two losses
eleven Arnon so the only people would
have lost so far are Dingley Randi on
the pony she Sergey Kirk in Vishwanathan
Anand Magnus croissant in chocolate
memory arrow so six people without a
loss and Carlson and Mahmoud Europe are
also without a win so two of them seem
to be having a contest on who's going to
pull a Giri in this tournament but yeah
definitely an exciting match being vs.
Nippon Ichi and you know there were
there was a lot of discussion online on
who would Magnus prefer as his
challenger in 2020 World Championship
would he would he prefer maybe young
information or lingering as as his
challenger so also if you have an
opinion and that feel free to comment in
the comment section but yeah - two more
rounds to go it's gonna be very
interesting to see if neppo can take it
all the way or maybe Dean will take it
all the way as nipple blundered the game
against Anand in round one it's really
amazing that he climbed it back on top
you know
- two rounds before the end of the
tournament so we're gonna see how it
goes so once again I do hope you enjoyed
it was a really intensive grind so hope
you enjoyed that I would like to thank
Matthew
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serie thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the sing Feld
Cup continue the capablanca saga we're
gonna check out Vancouver style from the
1962 Kurosawa tournament and of course
checking up on your excellent
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day